there was a horrific attack in Paris
just within the last couple hours and
we've got some video from ABC News ten
minutes after noon a quiet Paris side
street when a car pulled up gunmen
jumped out and according to eyewitness
video which you will see and here opened
fire with automatic weapons and if you
listen closely the gunmen holler out
Allahu Akbar as they fire upon this
weekly satirical newspaper that had a
long history of tweaking all religions
including Islam the newspaper had been
fire bombed before for publishing those
infamous cartoons of the Prophet
Mohammed this was a much more deadly
attack there was actually a police
officer guarding that paper that officer
was killed as you say there are 11 more
dead ok so this story is still unfolding
as we record this right now these images
obviously we're seeing this stuff just
every day so we're gonna show you a
couple covers from the Charlie Hebdo
newspaper so they were an equal a true
equal opportunity offender here they are
with the Pope so that's obviously a
knock on Christianity here's what
appears to be a Orthodox Jew I wish my
French was better so I could understand
that I see Palestine in there and then
of course the next one is Mohammed now
obviously the Danish cartoon incident
which I think was in 2011 caused a lot
of craziness I feel like we're becoming
just so insanely desensitized to this
stuff like I woke up this morning I see
a zillion tweets about it you watch
another video people screaming shots and
it's just like well it happened in
Australia two weeks ago France they've
been having all kinds of problems over
the last couple years anyway like how
desensitized are you to this kind of
stuff I remember back when South Park
did this and it was or was a Family Guy
yeah I don't remember who did what but I
definitely have seen a Family Guy with
Mohammed in it yeah they both they both
have had Mohammed in them yeah it was a
throw away and the South Park made fun
of them they're like well we're gonna
get revenge on America and they made
their own cartoon or like I'm a third
American I hope babies out of wedlock
you darling it was back then we thought
oh it's so you know it's so satirical
and funny and original but maybe you're
right
we are a little desensitized to it now
yeah what do you think first of all how
do you know that looks like Muhammad it
looked exactly the same as the comic
before it yeah it looked like the Jew
right that's so how do we know it's not
a Jew dressed up like his friend
Muhammad that's another thing we need to
clarify and I'm sure Jesus had a friend
named Muhammad yeah for sure I'm just
saying like the whole idea is there were
never any photos of Muhammad or drawings
nor depictions images so so we don't
know if that really is what he looks
like I think it's just so bright but
that's so prism it's so presumptuous and
so frustrating on the part of these
militants they need to understand
outside of outside of their little world
that there's this whole big world but
they just don't give a [ __ ] like I get
it I get that and I see that already on
Twitter people are trying to like
rationalize it in a weird way but I
don't understand why especially people
on the left that should be for free
speech like they just don't give a [ __ ]
so what are we don't even [ __ ] terms
they don't like they can listen to you
and be like oh well brett erlich said
that there's a bigger world out there
and we should respect other people's
beliefs but that's not in the very
belief system yeah here's the thing it's
like no one's gonna come to defense of
the comedian's I don't think that's the
problem and all the comedian's like wait
we should be able to tell jokes
[ __ ] ran let's pay attention right now
but don't you think about it like who's
this isn't like a school of people was
bombed and even when a school of
children is bombed people do move on
it's such a it's such a difficult
impasse that we're at honestly don't
know right that's actually a good point
because I even when I preface this story
I totally skipped over what happened in
Pakistan literally two weeks ago with
the hundred something dead children so
isn't that like the most perverse part
of this that they're attacking basically
this magazine is the equivalent of the
onion in France so this is a true direct
attack on free speech like in a weird
way this is this is sort of the worst
thing they could do right do you feel
that we're maybe giving them too much
leeway and rationalization in that way
like oh well this is just what they do
and we we need to work around it I don't
think anyone wants to work around it
it's just we don't know how to work
through it yeah like that's the problem
I mean yeah I mean that's the danger is
people get it feels like lazy and
they're just like ah
I mean well there yeah let's what are we
gonna do tomorrow but but I honestly
don't know how to engage it and I do
think that if we I'm giving them a
probably as much credit as they deserve
in that this is part of their tactic
this is the death by a thousand cuts
this is you know either I mean we can't
like bomb Paris by and large we need to
go do all these little attacks so that
it's more just this nebulous feeling of
dread that you have yeah you guys
terrorism works right so do you think
what they want ultimately is for the
French authorities and the French
government then to start cracking down
on freedom of speech even more becoming
more afraid of allowing to show images
like this
thus they don't even have to do it like
that sort of that's sort of the
brilliance of terrorism in a weird way
they don't have to take away your
freedoms through terror they just force
the government to start restricting your
freedoms themselves also I think part of
the strategy it depends on who's
perpetrating this but if if the strategy
is to establish an Islamic state this is
part of the tactic the part of the
strategy this is the tactic that gets
you to focus on Paris and not you know
the Middle East right so now we're we're
we're playing defense on our own turf
this is taking the fight to France so
that France won't necessarily be more
inclined the more attacks are
perpetrated on the streets of France the
less inclined the French government will
be to not necessarily police around
Paris in terms of like free speech but
more like contribute to the effort to
put down Isis yeah do you guys think
that in a weird way this actually might
sort of help look in America we have a
different free speech than they have in
in Europe they don't have free stuff
they don't have the First Amendment the
way we have it here thanks people right
well they don't have it fully you're not
allowed to deny the Holocaust there's
different there's different hate speech
rules things like that but do you think
in a weird way this actually sort of the
reverse question of what I asked second
whether this actually may sort of help
the the freedom fighters the people that
believe in free speech and the satirist
and the comedians because I just on
Twitter already in the last hour the
amount of people that I saw that we're
posting the cartoon and saying [ __ ] this
we can't be tolerant of intolerance so
we actually so in a weird way they
actually might be strengthening the
people that they're trying to
unintentionally for sure I mean
certainly the intended effect is free to
be like oh I'm scared okay
we better not do this then we better
like do what they want yeah and that's
the natural thing to move in but clearly
that's what the desired effect is of
these terrorists so no yeah
all right well certainly there's no
answer to that and this since this thing
is still unfolding we will find out
[Music]